こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん子供の頃は何して遊んでましたか
僕子供の頃ためすごい割合の良い小学生でしたあの外で遊ぶのがちょっと50%中で
遊ぶながちゃんと50%つってなんか
分部領土できてましたね幼少期の頃に僕を作りやすてるものがあったんですよひとつ
それがこちらいうブロックこれは去ったことある人いますか
北防これ
曾孫でてもう多分皆が引きますよもう引くぐらいそれで遊んでてねこれさえあれば何で
も作れるんじゃ行かないから持っててこういう感じで色々ドロップが入ってるんです
けどもこれまでなく適応力がすごすぎて今何か作れていたすぐ作れますよぽん今パッと
思いついたですねもうこれでも県作れますからねこれ完全に剣ですこのケアかっこよく
しよってた僕はも止んでもできますか
ね完全ザッツ面とセイバーこれも風じゃっ抓ったセイバーで作ることができました
いくら良いですね僕もこれに育てられたと言っても過言ではないです
ニューブロックさえいれば何でもできると思ってたんで今回なんといい
can you do
考慮中に終わってと183張っておりますってことは
183かけ中には2 j
196相手に全196方にブロックがあるんですけども大人になって俺のつけた見せて
僕もいい年でも24です横存知になればもうもう
やばいよどうなのーだねくんってみてもう異常なことになってるんでこれだけの服が
あれば1とんでもないものが作れると思うのでちょっと今回はこれ
の湯へメッだって多いランチこれ二つしかなかった2つではっとはっと楽しんでいたの
にもう10肉まんから最高に楽しめると思います今日あれのブロック技術を見せてやる
と思う
まずイメージを切るかが大事なんですね何度かくっついてんだ
代筆屋ドラゴンな僕はドラゴン大好きなんです
me
あれ
新たどうぞ
[音楽]
ええええ
ヘイマン米マンドゥ何年
なんでなんでなんではっはー女ちょっ
ブーフはあああああ
あああああああああそれでも限界がもう限界かもこれ上記するとタオル
あっはぁっ
って待って誰の上へ
やらかしたはこれあのこれは水であってですね
何でもちょっとまじゃあやだー
ああああああ
心ミスで rar
てい
ok ee
ダムドランダムず以前止めガゼータ xx
人サンバル54ですあのチクったなぁ
ちょっとロボット外で補足作りすぎててこれ以上多分何か粒とすぐ倒れるんですよぷっ
続けるとすぎております
ちょっと難しいどれだけ数があっても結局バランス捉えて崩れることがなかったので
あまりすぎだな
もうちょっと公フレイも大きくしたら大きくなったのかなと思います
ちょっと真っ先に見せ組を正キーチョコって
[音楽]
すごくねまずで言ってる
me
car
amaran
本当にすごいと思ってるん
これだよ
うんマジ
パーシーなし